A king and a queen had a baby and named her Aurora.
Many visitors came to see the baby,...
...including three good fairies.
Their names were Merryweather, Fauna and Flora.
Another visitor was a king who brought his son, Prince Philip.
A wicked fairy also visited and cast a bad spell on the baby.
She said that Aurora would prick her finger...
...on the needle of a spinning wheel and die.
Fortunately, one of the good fairies was able to change the spell.
Aurora would not die but only fall asleep.
Only the kiss of her true love would wake her up.
On the night of her 16th birthday,...
...Aurora pricked her finger and fell asleep.
Prince Philip kissed her and she woke up.